[Applause]
let me just provide a very brief welcome
I thank you for coming to this event
this evening to this annual tell Berg
foundation Global Leaders Forum we
really want to acknowledge United
Nations Deputy Secretary General John
alias and former Deputy Secretary
General I have seen him a little bit in
operation and I can say I was
immediately impressed both by his
obvious diplomatic skills but also by
the substance of what drives him and
it's really a credit to him that we have
these sustainable development goals
which is an enormous achievement for the
world I also want to recognize Carol
Dweck whom I'll turn this over to in a
second Carol has been the indefatigable
leader of the Committee on global
thought and the inspiration behind
making this the success that it is at
Columbia and to the Chaka Desai who has
joined us from the Asia Society a number
of years ago and has played many roles
at the University not least of which is
working with Carol and the faculty and
the students in creating this thing we
call the Committee on global thought
which is not self evident and obvious
what it should be but they've made it
into something truly quite wonderful
so we have these young leaders not the
usual kinds of people that we honor at
the end of their life for great
achievements but something at the
beginning not people just the promise
people who have and are doing things in
the world that are deeply admirable for
which we should be incredibly grateful
and we get to listen to them
and honor them and the last thing I
would say that as I understand the tell
Berg foundation and its mission and the
yon aleus and the Committee on global
thought we're all trying to figure out
really what roles institutions can play
in the world it's just a great great
puzzle because we all know that the
problems are massive and we all know
that the traditional institutions that
we call upon to deal with these are
hampered for any number of reasons and
so we're trying to invent it seems to me
a new global system of governance and
policy and effects at the same time that
were recognizing these great problems so
I view tonight as one of these little
moments when you find out that there are
people who've done incredible are doing
incredible things sort of on their own
and can make it into something really
quite special and we just can't do
enough of this in the world and
universities should be places not only
that honor individuals like this but we
both foster it and do everything we can
to try to help
thanks very much Carol
[Applause]
well I'd like to add my welcome to all
of you to the welcome of the president
Bollinger this time on behalf of the
Committee on global thought we're very
happy to be able to co-sponsor this
event with the world leaders forum and
with of course the Talbert foundation
the idea of celebrating these incredible
global leaders who do so much good and
also do so much to inspire the rest of
us to try to do good so we thank them
for their global leadership and I'd also
like to thank them on behalf of the
Committee on global thought for leading
to student workshops tomorrow we
organized them they are 1990 graduate
students from 10 schools across the
university and more than 50
undergraduates from all four
undergraduate schools and these two
workshops sold out in two hours we had
to change the place and we had to turn
people away which i think is a sign of
the interest among students in global
things and also their hopes to follow in
your incredible footsteps now among
these students are 25 students in the
master's program in global thought will
come from around the world with diverse
backgrounds and they all come equipped
with hope and ambition and their
ambition is to contribute to making the
world a better place
and in the undergraduate workshop you
will have the members of our
undergraduate Committee on global
thought and many of their colleagues who
are interested in their work under
president Bollinger guidance Columbia
has become a truly global University and
you really feel it when you speak to the
students and their response to your
generosity and leading their workshops
is an indication of that and I also like
president Bollinger would like to thank
the shocked
sigh who as the vice chair of the
Committee on global thought brought the
Talbert Foundation here today she was a
juror for this year's Global Leadership
Award and she's an invaluable Colombia
person when I was reading the Tao Berg
foundation information I was really
struck by how many of the same words and
same missions that the foundation has
and they share with the CGT or I should
say we share with you because I'm sure
you were there first but it it was
heartwarming to me to think that it's we
all have a similar idea the mission of
the CGT when it was from the Committee
on global thought was founded by
president Bollinger in 2006 and it it
was his vision which we are trying still
to implement and make real and when I
read it in the talbert brochure about
Talbert is going to be a platform it's
going to be a network for and I quote an
ever-widening global as possible
conversation and I thought yes that's
what we're trying to do to the Committee
on global thought reaches across the
university across the city and around
the world
and our goal is to think across
scholarly disciplines across national
borders and outside that box we all
talked about of conventional categories
to better understand and also improve
the world in which we now live if you
one example so from our current research
project called thoughts on a changing
world which is I think quite true to the
tradition both of the Talbert Foundation
and of global Colombia the first topic
in the first phase of this research
project which is a multi-year
transnational project the first topic is
called youth in a changing world and I
think it's worth telling you how that
happened
we chose the subject as a result of a
global conversation
ten cities with nine with panels in nine
of Colombia's global centers and it
turned out that in all ten cities from
Beijing to Rio everyone said we are most
concerned about the future of youth
youth and technology youth and work
youth and identity youth and civic
participation and so we crowd sourced
our research project we globally came to
that conclusion and now as we embark on
it we are continuing to do it in a
global conversational way acting as a
network in a platform and I hope that
that is in the telomeric foundation
spirit as well as in that of the
Committee on global thought so I think
you can see why the Committee on global
thought is both honored and grateful to
have you here at Columbia and to
celebrate these amazing global leaders
who are making every effort and
succeeding in doing real good and real
work in the world it's now my pleasure
to introduce a land soga Stoeger who is
the chairman of the talbert foundation
and from what I understand the driving
force behind the present shape of the
Leadership Awards
[Applause]
Thank You Carol for the introduction
Thank You president Baum and Juran this
feels like home we may not leave
I am Alan's dog I am chairman of the
tell Berg foundation what I'd like to do
in a few minutes is a couple things
first I'd like to tell you who the tell
Berg foundation is and what we want to
be our backstory starts about 35 years
ago our founder a Swedish businessman
named Bookman was one of Volvo's senior
executives and boo was an extraordinary
person boo understood that if you talk
to yourself long enough you will know
nothing and he realized that that's what
Swedish business was doing they were
talking to themselves they were
tremendously successful but boo
understood that could not possibly last
unless he broadened out the conversation
so 35 years ago in the widow town a
gorgeous little town called tel burg
which you pronounce much better than I
do by the way which is in middle Sweden
boo convened a conversation 30 people
they were all men at that time 20
businessmen ten academics experts in
industrial organization experts in Japan
experts and all sorts of things and they
started talking and that's where Talbert
comes from it eventually was
institutionalized after a fashion and
we're still talking we fundamentally
believe that if you convene the right
people in the right place to talk about
the right things you're going to make
progress but it's important that they're
not the same people they're not the same
places there are no borders in
information anymore and there can't be
any borders in conversations so we try
to do as we talk about things like
climate change like mass migration the
impact of new technologies on society
there growing conflict between gold
globalization and economic nationalism
we want our conversations to have three
characteristics first in my colleague
tom
means we'll meet in a moment mention
this today as we met all day we're
actually looking for questions not
answers we actually think we're in the
business of trying to find better
questions because most of the questions
being asked seem to be the wrong ones
second I'm a firm believer I'm not much
in the Bible but I'm a firm believer in
Noah's Ark what you want in a good
conversation is two of lots of different
kinds of things so if you want to talk
about unemployment don't bring 30
economists bring two economists and two
artists and a couple of poets it's that
mix that creates great conversation we
had an example a couple years ago we
convened a conversation at CERN outside
Geneva at the Large Hadron Collider and
it was two days talking about evolution
and it was evolution of the universe of
the planet of social organizations of
mankind and at the end of it a Nobel
physicist comes up to me and he says as
they always do at the end of these
meetings best meeting I've ever been at
now if you're the host you're not
supposed to say why I said why and he
said I go to I'm an academic what I do
is go to conferences for a living
I give papers but and I'm the expert but
at this conference I've been at first
workshop I've been at that I could be
stupid I said what does that mean I
could ask questions I wasn't just
answering questions I wasn't just
telling people my theories I was talking
to artists about evolution I was talking
to economists about mankind so we
believe in this sort of Noah's Ark of
conversations thirdly as I said we're
borderless we believe in pitching our
tent wherever it makes most sense so if
you want to understand migration go to
lesbos Greece which we did two years ago
and have the conversation there you want
to understand climate change go up in
the ice sheet in northern Greenland
spend some time with with the scientists
drilling ice core you'll have a better
idea if you want to understand the
impact of technology and evolving
technology on science go up to Kendall
Square and talk to great scientists go
to the Large Hadron Collider and in the
context of great science
you're gonna learn something and frankly
that's why we're here today if you want
to have a conversation about global
leadership where else should you go
except to Columbia and to the Committee
on global thought so that's why we're
here and thank you very much for hosting
us tonight our program has two anchor
points and of course they're going to be
conversations not presentations we're
not really good on presentation the
first will be a conversation between
vishakha desai and anyon Eliason and I'm
sure that I can't possibly add anything
to what you already know about for Shaka
she is the real force of nature in this
room not me
but what she has taught us for three
years as we work together on this
project is what the word global really
means every time we wander off in the
wrong direction we get a reminder it has
to be global you have to think globally
you can't let that word disappear or
that concept disappear thank you for
that jana liason who most of you
probably don't know is simply one of the
most successful and most committed
international diplomats of our era he
has a long resume he was most recently
the deputy secretary-general of the
United Nations before that he had been
the president of the UN General Assembly
he had been foreign minister of Sweden
he'd been ambassador and with I don't
know what hat you were wearing when you
did that but he negotiated in the
iran-iraq war he negotiated in the
Balkans he negotiated throughout African
conflict situations and perhaps most
importantly and it's something I've
learned from you yan
this is a dark world it's a world where
lots of things are going wrong and I
once asked John how do you get up every
day and he says because I have to
because somebody's got to get up every
day you've got to do it so he taught me
about optimism and that a great leader
has to be optimistic has to have values
has to be courageous and has to get up
every morning so vishakha and Yan are
going to talk a bit about the world a
world
is global but doesn't seem to want to
stay global and that balance between
what we know has to be and and what it
seems to want to be the second part of
our program will also be a conversation
among this year's Talbert global leaders
tonight you'll meet four people plus my
colleague Roderigo rabito Alonzo an
architect co-founder and executive
director of instituto LS now I have to C
based in Santos Brazil that is dedicated
to participative leadership community
mobilization and community building
Rebecca Heller the director and
co-founder of the international refugee
assistance project I wrap which is
headquartered in New York and I suspect
cell phones around the world and
operates globally which organizes
lawyers and law students to develop and
enforce legal and human rights for
refugees and displaced persons Fiorenza
omen Otto the Frank Doble professor of
engineering and a professor of
biomedical engineering at Tufts
University who has pioneered the use of
silk as material platform for advanced
technology with application and
photonics optoelectronics and
nanotechnology it's really cool stuff
and bright Symons technology innovator
development activist and social
entrepreneur based in Ghana whose work
challenges the received wisdom about
social and economic development
strategies and programs in Africa but
but well beyond Africa my colleague on
the TEL berg bort Tom Cummings will
explore with these leaders how they are
working to affect dramatic positive
change in the complicated world that
yawn and vishakha are going to describe
before we get to these conversations I
want to introduce what we're trying to
do in the leadership space conventional
wisdom today is that leadership is in
short supply
we believe that conventional wisdom is
wrong we may be more than a bit short
particularly in this country at this
moment in political leadership but we
firmly believe that there are many
individuals with vision with talent
courage and values in many spaces in
many places who are hard at work to
change the world for the better
the Tobruk foundation is committed to
finding these leaders honoring them
building a network among them and in
doing so encouraging others to follow
their examples the four leaders that
were going to listen to an honor tonight
were selected by an international jury
of nine women and men from around the
world including vishakha they reviewed
more than 200 nominations from 50
countries and these were business with
people they were political leaders they
were social activists entrepreneurs
religious leaders and all of those
nominations were done by ordinary people
the way our process is entirely online
all of you should nominate people next
year the only people on the planet earth
that cannot nominate are the nine or ten
judges because we don't want conflicts
the leaders you're going to meet I think
after you listen to them for a little
bit you will agree that the jury got it
right once again I think we're we've
done this three years in a row we're
three and oh and and I think that's good
start and now it is my honor and an
extraordinary privilege to introduce two
dear friends
Vishakha Desai and Jana Eisen please
as Alan mentioned you've you have so
many different experiences in your 40
plus year of amazing career I could ask
you about un I'm not going to do that I
could ask you about all the different
conflicts you have resolved we're not
gonna do that either
but to really kind of get at this
question of the global condition that we
are in today you've seen everything and
at the same time we recognize that today
even the word global seems to be under
attack attacks from many different
forces whether it's so-called
nationalism populism ethnic strife how
do you think about that notion of the
word global under attack and at the same
time trying to find a new path that
brings you because you're at the mitad
globalist yeah and to find a new path
what is that new path well let me start
with the Allens recognition of me as an
optimist I forced myself to be an
optimist but I think I want to qualify
it and say that in today's world I'm a
worried optimist and having served in
the United Nations for many years in the
last five years I think the United
Nations is a reflection of two things
it's a mirror of the world as it is and
it's not a pretty place but it's also a
mirror of the world as it should be and
I don't think we should ever forget that
that we have the direction given in the
UN Charter and by the values that tell
my stance for a new at your university
stand for and that we must never give up
it's so crucial not least my you young
people to realize that nobody can do
everything but that everything
everybody can do something and we have
different roles I think in today's world
with the challenges that we have ahead
of us we need to see that there is a I
think a great need to work across
borders yes these things are pretty
tricky to work across borders both in
terms of in my area and the Arab nations
peace and security development Human
Rights there's no peace without
development no development without peace
and there is none of the above without
respect to human rights but also and I
thank president Bolger for that that the
universities and all other actors the
private sector civil society you and me
and all of us need to be mobilizing now
to stand up for these common values that
we can only do it if we mobilize
horizontally there is too much far too
much of vertical organization far too
much of silos of course we have to be
extremely good in our silenced vertical
but when we want to solve problems in a
burn we better go horizontal and by that
I don't mean go to sleep by the way so I
think that we okay there is a need to
make sure that there is no immediate
contradiction between the global the
national and the local and I think we
need a more passionate story about the
global dimension I usually say about
passion by the way that without passion
nothing happens in life but I also think
that without compassion the wrong things
happen and we need to have a more
driving compassionate story narrative
about is one of the issues that you have
talked about and that is that when we
use the word global it feels very
abstracted it feels as my husband says
global schmoeville you know I it does
really jump out it's a very American
thing what can I tell you but that it
varies when we think about religion when
we think about ethnic strife when we
think about even nationalism populism as
is used today not always how it's used
there's certain emotion that's attached
to it you have lived that idea of global
and you're passionate about it so how do
we bring that notion of passion and make
it less abstracted to people so they
feel like they can see themselves in it
and you began very early with this well
first of all I think we shouldn't have a
contradiction between national and
international in fact I said at an early
discussions they I'm very patriotic
about my own country and I don't want
people on there particularly the
right-wing in Europe in my country to
steal my pride in my own country I'm a
true patriot but I'm also an
internationalist and one should
understand that in fact the word
identity if you ask yourself how often
do you use the word identity you
probably use that word very often but
have how often do you use it in terms of
plural
I think we should accept that identity
this identity is much better in plural
than in singular I'm a sweet I'm
European I'm born citizen neither you
can go all across the field and I think
that sense of of having a broader view
that you don't see a contradiction
between what you do at home and what you
do internationally is something we have
to achieve and where did it begin for
you how did you know you want to go back
to - we are both American field service
students 17 years old we went to the
United States he was seven years I was a
party guy
I was I was we went on a bus tour around
the states and and there were two girls
quarreling in front of me I was in the
backseat to get some sleep after the
party from the night before you know age
18 and they spoke so much there was a
Greek girl and a Turkish girl they
quarreled about this about Cyprus and I
had to listen to it like you have to
listen to mobile phone conversations on
their train on the bus and at the end I
got tired of this 20 minute quarrel
between the truth I leaned over to them
and said well now listen to you for so
long but I think I have a solution for
you for Cyprus so I suggested that the
Turkish minority would have more of
minority rights be assured rights in the
parliament and maybe Indian government
and that's how you could probably solve
this otherwise that would be a great
separate majority running the country
forever and they looked at me said oh oh
you should work at the United Nations
but we don't have too much time I think
we were promised we asked you the
optimum size I mean it worries their
worries are so yeah I don't need to
bother I spent a lot of time working on
the nuclear risks involved in the Korean
situation I'm chair of the Stockholm
International Peace Research Research
Institute we have of course the facts
that conflicts now turn out even more
difficult than ever before because they
easily turn into proxy wars Syria we
have the climate change which is an
extensional issue which we must take
seriously the word responsibility is
perhaps the most important word for that
so you can go along and also this
division of us and them and and the sort
of hesitation about everybody's equal
worth all this is very worrying but hope
just forwards for hope from me and you
may have your view on this one the
biggest hope is women women's full Masri
and empowerment will come soon it is has
to come it will come is going to be the
greatest positive news in the world for
the first time in history this will
happen and if you particularly women
feel that it's going slowly and people
start mobilizing against it that's
it's getting serious and the big thing
is for this to become not only a
question of emancipation of women but
emancipation of man men and women
together it's gonna be the biggest
improvement positively in the world
secondly young people you here I think
we should not only think we in my
generation about what we can do for use
which we should do but we should also
think what we can do with youth with
youth and we are in hurry to get you in
on the decision-making processes the
little deliberations in all fora and I
think there is a tremendous force in
that thirdly knowledge universities
scientific community if we are to Iraq
that you mentioned the sustainable
development goals we if we if these are
to become a reality before 2030 we need
to really get the scientific community
on board for health climate transport
energy everything and the last thing
that I really want to bring out is
international cooperation the most
important word in the world today is
together with the side of responsibility
together and above all I think we in
today's world have a huge deficit of
dialogue and diplomacy Russians and
Soviet diplomats are called back
reducing their presence State Department
evidently is not fully fully fully full
it's actually 30 percent reduction we
have very little dialogue across lines
like North Korea and the United States
goes always the same
this style of deficit is extremely
dangerous and I think with you here
think about the enormous power in
preventive diplomacy in a creative
diplomacy so these are the four hope
factors that make me in the end
optimists maybe without the restriction
of worried it seems to me that when you
talk about being a worried optimist when
you start talking about your optimism I
sense that the worried kind of recedes
and you get very excited so if you were
to think about new kind of leadership as
you I mean you've seen many many leaders
and you have to be very diplomatic when
you were at the UN what characteristics
have you found in this new world context
that you think are particularly
important in the leader and what are the
characteristics that you think are
really a problem when you see it in a
leader I was three years in the Navy of
Sweden and I had a situation where our
ship was in great danger and I looked at
the bridge where I was standing after
this storm and I looked at the striped
guys there with the who were they on the
bridge but the ones that had saved us in
that situation where was the guys in the
machine room with their tattoos and hurt
by the throne or between the engines and
I went down to thank them and that has
characterized at least my way of working
that you realize that you have your own
role but you have to work together with
others and give them their
responsibility and then I always
appreciate when there is a sense of very
great great degree of openness there is
a story a fairy fairy tales with author
by the name of HC Anderson he has
written this fantastic fairy tale about
the Emperor without clothes and the
little boy who says that he's naked we
need to have people who say come back to
some basic issues and honestly raised
the problems and by that height and the
the the dialogue and then I of course I
think you should since you are in you're
in these formative years is to be
extremely good in what you're studying
what you're doing but also understand
that your life will be so much more
interesting and you will be much more of
a problem solver if you open the doors
to others who see the problem from
different other directions
it's not only a good way to get the
solutions it's also more fun because
when you see it from different
you get a much greater sense of
community and the realization that you
have to be a team in the end to do it so
these are some of the things that I'm
thinking about but then also there
should be an element of let's say fun I
want my staff to bounce to work this
might be that's too much to ask but you
know there's that they know that it's
gonna be something that we have together
and that we will solve together and when
I have that sense that they run with the
ball I go home and as my daughter Anna
knows I fall asleep within seconds she's
a graduate of Columbia where they and I
think the the fact that we have the
world is such a troubled place but we
got to make sure that we make it a place
where we see challenges throw them
problems of parents so with this idea of
fun they're even 40 years ago for you
the idea of fun little lady right yeah
I'm going to open it up we just have
time for a few questions
before we go to the next panel so if you
have an urgent question especially for
Yan please raise your hand identify and
come to the microphone you can't be that
shy come on yes hi I'm interested
you said the greatest hope is in women
what about say young people right what
do you have to do no but it's so obvious
that the so obvious that the voices of
women are not heard in so many contexts
I have mediated in six conflicts from
Iran Iraq to Darfur and no never have I
have seen a woman in the delegation on
the other side so we have resolution
1325 in the UN but it has it's far too
slow there but when I have been planning
the negotiations the different
situations I've already
made sure that and my delegation are
women and that that I'm inviting women
to the negotiations and where they come
you get a much more hands-on oriented to
the field to the home to the family
approach which really adds that passion
that you need to bring into the
negotiations but I think generally also
it's a tremendously untapped resource
apart from the human dignity which is
not respected I mean it simply says
suppose in the UN Charter and in the
university for Human Rights that we were
born free and equal and we have to live
up to that and and I think it's also a
probably more fun that it's gonna be a
vitalizing force and it is going to
happen but I think it's important that
all the men are seeing that as
liberation of man not as women only I
could give you many examples how helpful
it is to see the perspective from the
women and it is coming when I go to
Rhonda more women than men in the
parliament if I go to West Africa as
many my African friends knows some over
here they are dominating the trade in
their countries if you go look at the
number of presidents women in Africa and
Asia so over the place Latin America so
it is coming and it's going to be a
great and positive force thank you and
we cannot take any more so just a two
more but brief questions yes I thank you
both
I just want to know briefly about if you
could talk a little bit about diversity
especially with organizations based in
northern Europe and areas like Sweden
that are not typically heterogeneous
communities and also I wanted to know
when you say work a cloth across borders
it feels a little bit generic to me so I
was wondering if you could give a little
bit more in depth examples of like what
that means in terms of action based
performances thank you
well by borders I don't mean only
Geographic borders I also mean borders
within society the different horizontal
combinations you can have with the
different actors governments
Parliament's by the way very important
private sector universities science
world civil society but I think the the
dynamics that comes from from that
border crossing is absolutely crucial
but I think the most important most
urgent issue to handle in that
perspective is the migration and refugee
issues we have now a situation in the
world with 244 million migrants 65
million refugees if we don't turn the
narrative into from a very negative
narrative in Europe this is seen as a
problem Imperial not as a potential or
possibility if we don't see this as a
historic turning point where we need at
least to make that narrative neutral if
not completely positive because it is a
bit of a challenge for any society but
if we don't see for instance what IMF
and our city has proven that it is a
great addition to to the GMP in most
countries to have the migration it's
also for the demographic development
crucial we would have negative
population growth in Western Europe
without a migration if you look at
remittances from the migrants you will
see that the remittances in value are
three times the official development
assistance in the world so what that
means for the villages sincere Lankan
Philippines and so forth is incredibly
important and lastly we all have to ask
ourselves now do we want to go the
direction of diversity or exclusion this
is a crucial situation which we find
ourselves you with you're in the United
States in Europe and that debate has to
come to - in my view to the conclusion
that we we have this irresistible force
of international cooperation getting
more and more serious and in my own
country I have given a speech at
national day couple years ago and they
asked me to speak pass Sweden in the
world and they wanted me speak about our
commercial growth
can't burn adults and so forth I did so
but then I insisted to have a second
part I've only told half the story
Sweden in the world yes but we also have
to think that the world is in Sweden a
with ideas with products and with people
and that's when you have a complete
picture of this approach of you know
working across borders that you also
realize that the migration issue is
actually basically now grown Lee an
integration issue last question so in
speaking to your career as a serial
diplomat what characteristic of your
temperament do you think has contributed
most to you being a successful conflict
you know negotiator or for you to be
successful that's a great question
first of all I have to hide my passion
so you got to be controlled and listen
but I I see I want to say to you I want
to share with you four reasons in very
brief terms for reasons to fail or to
succeed in negotiations mediation and if
you go very far if you succeed in life
but that's perhaps too presumptuous
first of all respect for the word the
word collect words no five-six synonyms
sit at the talks realizing that you can
change the wording change the paragraphs
without losing the substance and then
you get it through sustainable
development goals negotiation was that
respect for the word I would say even
love for the world collect words I say
to my children and grandchildren
secondly the art of timing don't do
things too late
but equally seriously don't do it them
too early analyze timing in anything you
want to achieve when is the right time
and who should be helpful in the process
third reason is cultural sensitivity one
time in Tehran I made a mistake got
tired and said oh let's break up and
this was
translated to Farsi that I was gonna
leave and there was over so the foreign
minister and thus I got very upset and
it said whoa if you don't want to
negotiate what do you want to do and
then I said something which to begin
with was disastrous but then turned up
third out of a Lucky Strike I want to go
to your famous carpet Museum when you
really ask me what I want to do so I
went that Museum and afterwards they
pointed to me he's my friend because
they had recognized this guy from the
North Pole practically was interested in
the way the carpets the colors the the
patterns and how they were done by their
grandparents who was child labour had
done that so it was just the cultural
sensitivity which i think is a great
important factor and last thing very
importantly are now looking back at my
life in diplomacy personal relations
that you is still trust i can't expect
sympathy from sitting with sarah masane
which i did twenty eight hours or
together but respect that they know that
you're truthful and that they can trust
the kind of communication that you have
so with those four four four conclusions
about success or failure maybe that
could be answer to your question thank
you please join me in giving a big
[Applause]
[Music]
it's about pragmatic driven dreams I
think the the more this context of
application of natural resources becomes
front-and-center
the better we're going to do and I think
it's an awareness that has to leave the
scientific world it has to go into
everyday conversation and it has to go
beyond the imagination and wouldn't it
be great if the world were all
sustainable yes it would be but you you
really do need to have the small little
pieces that then build up to this end
result
[Music]
the art of architecture it's not for the
architects to tell people how they
should leave but it's how to to
understand people how to listen to
people but in terms of leadership one
thing it's it's realizing the the
knowledge the wisdom and the power of
those who you were leaders the leader
today really needs this openness to
listen and to buta together with people
it is for me a key ability filter for
leadership today is to understand the
richness of the wisdom of the others it
seemed obvious to me that if millions of
refugees all over the world were going
through a really complicated legal
system and that their lives depended on
the outcome that someone would have
suggested that they have lawyers my
whole philosophy of like global social
change as the effective work does not
divide the action from the messaging and
the news moves like we refer to it as
Airport weekend internally turnout
against the travel ban I think was
actually a perfect example of how
activism has to meld with influence and
the communications piece and the
symbolism piece in order to make like
really effective long-lasting change
to my mind
we need a new values driven leaders who
concerned themselves maybe need part of
the conversion and Politecnico and that
is the kind of leader I won't weaken but
in addition to that you can enrich the
broader ecosystem by helping others who
are primarily accountable for the
applications to develop and that's the
way I see my rule the only thing worth
pondering about what pursuing worth
exploring is the human attributes these
are all personal struggles to find our
place our biggest in this battle and
therefore our technologists didn't
release our struggle to do that enough
intelligence to mean that is the mark
and the heights
[Music]
good evening everyone my name is Tom
Cummings and I am very delighted to be
here and I want to give a special thanks
to to president Bollinger and and take a
look who just spoke and I wanted to just
make sure that if if we're here on
behalf of the Committee on global
thought that maybe the Tobruk foundation
is here for the for the group on global
action a little bit so we find this way
that we are working together to create
another way of not only thinking about
the world but engaging with the world
and for me it really starts by trying to
understand just as we heard from young
Eliason and vishakha that we're in a
world where we're going to have to take
into consideration some new ways of
doing things that doesn't mean we can't
learn from Jana Larson's experience but
we're going to be learning more from the
future perhaps than from the past as we
go forward the tobert leaders now the
Eliason global leaders are really a
remarkable group of people and I want to
get them up on the stage very very
quickly here I think that what's
characteristic of me for them is that
they're not only changing our
perspective on how we look at some of
the most challenging issues that we face
as Alan Stoeger said but they're
changing our conception of what we need
to be doing and that that difference is
subtle but important it's also
interesting to see that the selection of
this group of people starts with their
significance in their work I don't know
if you know and in in my life
the world seems to have been divided
over the years from people either saying
oh or oh and when they say oh then I
really know something is happening I
really know that something is shifted
and each of these people in their own
way
has broken through on our conception of
what it is that we need to do in
different fields in different
perspectives I think it's important that
they all are known for their certain
significance but our hope is that they
become known for their that they become
prominent that that through this work
not only is Allen's toga said they
connect with each other but they find
these remarkable ways to really develop
a next generation way of doing something
and I'll describe what they're some
things are in a minute that transforms
what how we think what we do where we go
in the world and the perspectives that
we ourselves will take now I know that
there are a lot of folks in the in the
room who are graduate students right
raise your hand if your graduate student
this so we know who you are good and it
was not too long ago that this group of
people were also graduate students so I
just want you to know that we want to
have you see that they we still call
them young leaders whatever age they are
they're young in spirit as well so let's
start as Alan mentioned all of them and
I we were going to have a film able to
see the film at the end I'm going to ask
each of them to come up here we're going
to be on the panel but have a few
minutes of conversation that I'm going
to see people running to the microphones
and asking great questions and then
we'll we'll conclude and I'll hand it
back to to vishakha so first one up and
whom I'd like to invite and you know in
the theater we always applaud before
they speak so I think that's a good
thing to do
Rodrigo Rubidoux please come up in
Rodrigo
[Applause]
Rodrigo's going to help us understand
why architects may not be looking at the
world in the right way but he has a
group of architects who have taken a
really different tack
Rebecca Heller some of you may know
Rebecca she's traveled all the way from
Brooklyn she said I rap is her
organization and Alan has already
described the work that she's doing and
I think we really want to dig into
understanding how in such a short amount
of time
Rebecca has managed to or Becca as she
likes to be called made a difference in
a very challenging political environment
with a very challenging political topic
Fiorenzo a minute oh he won't say to you
the future is plastics but he will say
the future is silkworms and you'll hear
why in a moment and bright simon's
[Applause]
bright himself is responsible as well
for the creation of a couple of
institutions in money and n pedigree and
again we'll hear more from him I think
from what I've done in interviewing them
already in the case of bright-eyed say
your parents named you right so good I'm
just gonna take a seat here and we'll
get started so are you ready I've asked
each of them to consider who are they
what are they doing what do they know
now that they didn't know when they
started so what do they really know now
and what are the questions that they're
holding now as they take the next step
in what they're doing so oh you'd said
you were not ready though then I'm gonna
start with right now this is this is a
conversation right are you ready okay go
first so I'm a social entrepreneur so
it's kind of a lot of my life in Ghana
and I started the work that I do
currently for a position of anga not
many of you may be aware but every day
the number of people that die from
complications related to fake or
substandard medicines it's equivalent to
the number of people in two jumbo jets
one very famous public official in
Nigeria unfortunately now dead have
described it as the worst form of
terrorism or known to the majority of
the world
so think of it two jumbo jets of people
everyday died from complications related
to fake and substandard medicines and I
thought that was just something that
made me quite hungry so that is how I
started and we wanted a solution that
could be ubiquitous enough and that
solution was to build a system for
validating the pallet of medicines using
SMS eventually we learned that was a
much more complicated problem you know
just knowing as a consumer what are the
medicine about it cake is Jenny or not
is a great thing but it doesn't go deep
enough to approach the problem and the
difference between our social
entrepreneurs and commercial
interpreters is that we do want to end
the problem we don't want a paycheck
forever solving the same problem over
and over again so we decided to do what
we do now which is build an interactive
trust and to build an Internet of trust
means that we connect all the
stakeholders within the supply chain
from manufacturers regulators etc using
different technologies and also to
expand horizontally beyond medicines
into cosmetics automotive and the rest
the one thing that we found and that
wasn't too apparent to begin with I was
summarized it using a quote by Carl
Sagan the famous Carl Sagan who said if
you want to build an omelet from scratch
you first have to invent the universe so
we learned that you know if we really
wanted to build a supply chain founded
on trust then we have to implement the
secrets of schemes that connected
multiple actors together and that is
what makes our technology in a way quite
different from the way that technology
nowadays is presented to the world and
what do you know now that you didn't
know when you started that technology is
not merely the intervention it's also
the philosophy and ideology that makes
that intervention cause less harm and do
real good so it goes beyond the actual
intervention to the set of philosophies
and ideologies surrounding that
technology which gives us is through
potency and that is why we are now going
beyond simply providing technology
ecology
to check whether product is general not
and actually getting trust into the
entire ecosystem then types of life
change so to speak and the question
you're facing at the moment the one
question we're facing is to what extent
do we replace parts of the ecosystem
that is inherently corrupt so we are you
falling together easy example we do have
pharmacists that are sworn to protect
lives there are still selling fake
medicines yet we know that the best good
we can do or the greatest good we can do
is to improve the trust between patients
and health workers not to seek to
replace health workers by the same time
people I inherit liquor up the
inherently corrupt so how do we continue
to prepare this theory of change that we
need to activate trust within the
ecosystem while at the same time fight
enemies better comments there are
enemies vested interests that I'll pose
to the work we do and some of these
people are sworn to protect lives thank
you thank you
Rebecca can we all just bounce around
here I'm back i but you know who am i I
don't even I'm still trying to figure
that out
I I'm the co-founder and director of the
international refugee assistance project
which believes that refugees should have
rights and that they really don't have
any now the global framework that we use
to process refugees has not been updated
since 1951 and it's wildly outdated it
doesn't include people fleeing from
conflict so technically most people
fleeing from Syria are not actually
refugees and thus have no rights and it
doesn't protect anyone fleeing from
climate change which I think that mass
displacement as a result of climate
change is the major effect of climate
change that we'll all see in our
lifetimes and we're not prepared for
that so we started organizing lawyers
and law students to try to fight back
and to say how can institutions better
protect the rights of refugees and
as lawyers and law students how can oral
first his law students and then his
lawyers for most of us who passed the
bar exam how can we enforce that and a
thing that I've been thinking about this
year it's it's both the thing I've
learned and a question that I have I
think you know for us we were always
like I'm a very partisan person but our
organization is a very nonpartisan
organization because we feel that
refugee shouldn't be a political issue
unfortunately in the last few years
they've been hyper politicized both in
the US and in Europe and I've never
really thought of lawyers as great like
movement builders or great activists I
thought our role was more of like a
technical behind-the-scenes role and
then on January 27th when the travel ban
slash Muslim ban came down from
president Trump we put out a call to our
network and said everyone should go to
the airport because there's going to be
thousands of people who are midair who
when they took off from wherever they
were coming from had permission to land
in the US and will land as undocumented
immigrants are non immigrants
essentially and no one will know who
knows what will happen to them and
thousands of lawyers all over the
country on a very very cold January day
like when two airports and in the end we
were able to get 2,100 people released
from airports that were being turned
into black sites
so I think the takeaway for me from that
was that like you you have a lot of
tools in your toolbox and you can use
them in really surprising ways often in
the face of the most adversity possible
and the big question that I'm wrestling
with is like I'm tired like I think
everyone is tired and we're only and I'm
saying this like as an American and as
someone living in America or with the
effects of America but the question for
me is like we're only 11 months in how
are we going to keep this up for three
more years
good let's pick that up in a couple of
minutes I I think I think I'll start
with the thing that surprises that that
has that has changed about and my
perception that has changed through the
years is that materials actually hide an
enormous amount of surprises I'm a
technologist by training I used to work
with lasers and now I run I run a lab
that has scientists from all from all
disciplines architects artists Olympians
and we all work around with the
inspiration of taking nature's materials
to build things and it's and so we use
silk and - to build plastics but
plastics that are augmented so think
electronics that you can eat or pieces
of transparent material that contain a
polio vaccine that doesn't need to be
refrigerated or an invisible edible
coating that stores fruit without
without having to be refrigerated so
things that actually sort of bridge the
divide between technology and biology
and that have very profound very
profound global implications I think on
manufacturing and on availability of
therapies and on availability of food
and that
preserve also our our food supply chain
it's been sort of a magical journey for
me because it was absolutely unexpected
I really didn't work on silk before I
joined Tufts and it speaks to the
importance I guess of communication with
other people and finding like-minded
people that do want to leave an impact
and this this goes to great kudos to my
my dear friend and colleague David
Kaplan who was a tissue engineer that
has worked on this material for longer
than I have and and so where are we
going from here well and the question
you have but the question that I have is
how to replace plastics now to replace
plastics you said that very quietly I
did how to replace PLAs how to replace
flat exactly all right questions okay
good great go rego yes about myself is
that I I consider myself a much more a
creation of arrows than the creator of
arrows so I see myself as a better
person especially because of the people
that I have around me Alice that boots
and do the work every day I do part of
the work they do most of the work I
would say and I think my work it's
mainly despite my education on in
architecture the the my work is mainly
trusting in the human potential to do
good things for themselves and to other
human beings so we work to spread a
philosophy of transformation that relies
on the human rotation for cooperation
within diversity and more than that the
potential to build the sense of
community within diversity and despite
what we watching on the news every day
it is working my experience is working
in more than 400 communities in 49
countries in the world so this how far
we we got so till now
what I know now that I maybe I didn't
know the beginning is that it is
possible to transform the world believe
in into the world we dream of they
believe in this and my question is how
much time it will take and how we take
care of those who are engaged in this
mission I would say and I would say how
we take care of all of us so we don't
lose hope before we get there Thank You
Rodrigo very good so bright I'd like you
to help Rebecca with her question of how
do you sustain because you've been in
this game for quite some time so how is
Rebecca going to sustain over the long
term with only 11 months into what looks
like a long when I when we first started
like I said it was a lot of anger and
that was the drive anger was the drive
it's quite crazy that you walk into a
pharmacy to buy medicine for your your
little child and you stand 1/3 chance of
getting something that could kill the
child and so anger was enough to get it
going the truth though is that anger is
not enough over the medium term and you
have to find other values that are
important and it started from first of
all getting off this notion of being the
center you know to my mind and I think
we discussed this at one point
leadership is really about treating
other leaders and when it becomes about
other people's journey towards the same
passion that you currently feel about
the problem you are able to be more
objective to stand outside looking in
and that gives you renewed strength
because as they go through the gender
you've gone through and you see them
scale one level after the other it
rejuvenates your power your passion it
is just you in the center then you're
gonna be worn out much much much quicker
so what I found works in a decade of
doing this work now two things one is
very much how you leave
through others how you find the journey
that you've been through refracted
through the lens of other people that
are on the same journey and how that
region is your energy the second thing
is also obviously the fact that we can't
have this one course no matter how
passion out deep deeply involve you in a
particular course it helps to have some
other course as well and that is why I
have not only done this technology work
and to the exclusion of other way but I
have also been very politically involved
because one counterbalances the other
and I find out that if you're able to
work with at least two courses then when
there is a bit of a tailspin on the
other one the other one keeps you going
so those are the two things that I will
advise chuckling this is so so head your
bets as well fine - course you start
with anger I know I know Rodrigo you
start with dreams and I'm curious if
you're advising the development of
next-generation plastics what would be
the things that you would be saying or
encouraging with respect to dreams yes
well I know we are totally driven by
dreams so I mean that and we do we we we
talk about it in opposition to the
problems of solving mind so we we've we
feel that we lose a lot of energy when
you're all the time looking to the
problem it takes our energy away so I
mean having like the most you top
utopian dreams I feel for us is the best
strategy but to start with the small
steps so you can you can feel that it's
possible
so we dream big but we start small so we
start to gain confidence that is
possible if we if we go right away to
the big dream you get frustrated
so that's your that's your advice what's
your dream
please plastics with the lower with with
a high with a high voice no but we've
got a no wise silkworms I mean this is
something that went away in the Middle
Ages right it is but but they're back
yes
now nature has a way of building with
with with with its own bricks with its
with structural proteins and the things
that are different is that these
materials are variable are living and
and have multiple functions you can eat
them you can put them under your skin
they degrade when you tell them to the
grade so so it's it's really kind of a
different a different take on on
materials the the opportunities the
opportunities is like taking chemistry's
and flavors and smells and giving them
shape so you kind of break the form and
function of the object and so you can
really get two kind of utopian spaces
and I agree fully that you need to think
absolutely outside of the box which is
sort of like the reason why we have a
lot of unusual people in our lab but
then you you have to be very able to to
ride the middle and so to be able to
reduce the pragmatics and to execute
because otherwise you're stuck in a
storytelling regime and when I say you
know when I want to give a talk because
I'm an academic and that's what I could
have a clear but when I give when I give
a talk and I say eat your cell phone or
plant your cell phone we actually ate a
CCD camera that we made I think it's
okay just chase it with a lot of Scots
and and Rebecca one of the conversations
we had early on and I really challenged
you on this I said really easy for you
to be in a privileged position here in
New York working with refugees how do
you use that privilege how do you think
about that privilege I don't know if
being in New York and working with
refugees is a particularly privileged
position to be in right now but I'll
take the rest of the class
[Music]
no I mean I I started my project and we
still have project in the name because
that's how we think of it as a student
at Yale Law School and I have no
illusion that I mean maybe I him if I
were a better dreamer maybe I'd have
illusions about it but but no illusion
that we would have had the success that
we did as rapidly as we did without like
the backing of that institution and of
course just like get you know we don't
need to go into a spiel about sort of
like the socio-economic factors that
make someone like more or less likely to
get to go to Columbia or Yale or
wherever else
um suffice to say that I think you know
privilege isn't something you should
front about like I think it's not
helpful if you have privilege and I also
did I'm from California and I will say
that I did not know what privilege was
until I got to like New England and I
was like oh this is what like money is
but that's in a separate aside I mean I
just think that like you you have to own
that you have privilege and not try to
front and also not try to victimize
people with less privilege and then just
think about like okay I'm lucky I have
all this privilege like how do I like
deploy it to I hate that this word has
been co-opted but to disrupt things you
know as much as possible with great
privilege comes great responsibility
and you had a personal experience abroad
that brought some light to that I recall
I've had several personal experiences
abroad I I don't know which way talking
about Jordan or Zimbabwe and Jordan okay
sorry yeah I know I was doing I was
doing an internship the summer between
my first and second years of law school
and the upshot was that the NGO didn't
have enough for me to do and I have
things OCD thing about wasting time and
efficiency because like let's face it
we're all gonna die pretty soon so like
go for it right is how it that's what
motivates me I think that's the
obsession with my own mortality I'm sure
I know that's new
and I I got this idea I just kept
hearing about these Iraqi refugees in
Jordan I got this idea that I should go
meet some without any I wasn't like on
then I'm gonna start a project and then
something I'm gonna tell a bunch of
really fancy people at the Italian
Academy at Columbia about it and but I
just was really struck by the plight
that people were in and they all just
really seemed like they needed a good
lawyer
[Music]
there we go a bright is challenged with
corruption you're living and working in
some toasts and having to find a way
that people can dream and build their
own houses the first thing about
architects is aren't they the ones that
are always telling people what to do
right isn't how did you change that
around and how do you deal with folks
that are get in your way
first of we are like we realized that
people have better ideas than Venice for
how their lives could be better so this
is like kind of arrogant like attitude
for like that so we pretend that we know
how people can live better that I can
have better lives in the beauties that
we designed so so we we were amazed when
we started to ask people how the they
dream to live they had wonderful ideas
one wonderful solutions for their lives
and what what is good about it is that
when you follow like their solutions it
tends to to work better because it's
coming from them so it's it tends to
work much better it tends to to to
continues to be sustainable a long time
also the the issue about like corruption
in politics and I know we trust we trust
as I said in the beginning in the human
potential or for doing good things in
turn so no matter who we were dealing
with it
be like a drug dealer in a favela Brazil
of availa or the mayor of the city I
mean and we talked to that person
looking for his or her potential of
doing good things and we are amazing but
because we realize that all kinds of
people that we used to consider like bad
people people they they they still have
the ability to do good things we have
received like cooperation from people
that we call criminals they were doing
that for free to support their community
know this I believe that human beings
they have potential to do both things we
are not we are not like it's not like as
some people say that is we are
biologically or like we are naturally
like evil we do bad things because this
is like our pre primitive instinct we
have we have thought both potentials
together so it's how you stimulate
people so which which one of the
potentials we want to stimulate thank
you and and maybe just a last question
and we'll we'll ask for questions on the
mics but for our two technologists
there's a lot of discussion about
technology as being quite autonomous now
it's it's something can we control it is
it something that how do we relate it
back to human endeavors and the ways
that humans are going to make choices
about the future and is the genie out of
the bottle please
how long until the singularity there we
are my inspiration from you know the
famous philosopher Michael Polanyi
and you know he said a lot of greetings
of anyway in politics but his insights
that there are aspects of the way we
think there are not codify herbal
is very interesting because it has
implications for a lot of the ways in
which we look at the how technology
evolves globally at a global scale he
makes the argument that because it is
not everything we think that we can say
it also means that not all the rules are
specified we've had a great discussion
this afternoon about machine learning
what a machine learning can provide a
way out of that obviously what machine
learning cannot provide a way out of is
giving my technology purpose because
that discovery service contestant so
even if you could say look we're not
going to set up the rules they're going
to learn and they're gonna evolve you
still have to contend with this is your
peppers this issue of meaning and
whether as a society we can leave that
to try and arrow and how much risk we
are willing to bear so from a you know
equation around a singularity I I
strongly believe that the most important
contribution that technology can make is
enhancing human ability to collaborate
to each other if we pick that point then
it seems to me that total autonomy for
machines it's not something that we have
the means and the tools to comprehend at
this point and therefore there is going
to be a movement of people and active
agency on a part of people to bring back
the technology genie into the bottle I
see I see that happening and that one
area where it's very evident already is
this issue around permission list or you
trust me sighs but blockchain right it's
already evident that we will sue the
line that you can have the permission
that system or a trust-based a system
that it's not based on trust at all
it's quite evident now that unless
you're gonna become cryptographic
mathematicians you're gonna have to rely
on somebody to use the blockchain and
that requires trust right so I think
that is a great example of how sometimes
the vision that is promoted it's not
always in alignment we really think the
way that technology evolves its embedded
I go back to palana it's embedded and I
think because it's embedded culture in
the end week's hero can you add to that
very difficult to think
is a so famous diplomat once said I
guess I guess I am I am a worried
optimist about about these things as as
well I think I think ultimately I think
ultimately there is a there's a pace of
evolution of Technology right now and
and of introduction of new of new
engagement modes that at the technical
level that we might not even know how to
frame the problem yet and to a certain
extent we always think of AI as a as a
global as something that has global
impact that it may very well be
personalized and Inter interconnected
within within very very useful domains
so so and by that I mean that artificial
intelligence can augment the human and
very in very efficient ways and then
guide guide the human relationship on a
personal basis of them builds up builds
up to a similar perspective so we can
take some questions please just jump to
the mics we'd like to hear your name if
we could and my name is Henry Nass this
is a question for the silkworm related
person I wanted to know is there a
connection between silk and spiderweb
material connection between silk and
spiderweb materials that anything the
definition the biological definition of
silks is very broad and it's anything
that an organism produces outside with
with with a production system outside of
its outside of its own body so for
example even muscles produce a certain
form of silk spider spider silk is very
is very nicely but you have much less of
that because spiders tend to be
cannibalistic and silkworm silk is much
more available it's a commodity textile
material so that's why we use it and it
has a lot of the same
sort of and I do Zinda silk where are
you looking to synthesize both or only
depend on the animal resource so so so
there are efforts actually industrial
efforts right now in in that Mary
synthetic biology and material
production so there are at least four
companies that I can think of that are
synthesizing spider silk I want to go
back to the question on leadership
please next in your name please
hi my name is Noah um my question is for
all of the four panelists before us and
and it's it's I'll try to be brief it
seems to me that the sort of mission of
tall burg and the mission of of Columbia
is sort of a paradoxical one and that is
to institutionalize progress it seems to
be something that you four are trying to
do in sort of disparate fields and and
it's a mission which is tiring as
Rebecca sort of pointed out she said
she's tired
and but I think that the institutions at
work are also very tired she pointed out
your question please my my question is
what are the institutions that you are
trying to change in the fields in which
you're working in and how do you intend
to make your missions your projects your
initiatives institutions of progress how
do you ensure that they are going to
continue to change
so institutions you are changing through
the work they're doing I think the
biggest weakness in the global model for
problem solving right now is that local
innovators who are closest to the
problems are not getting global
amplification that is the biggest
problem the people that are close to the
problems really know what the problem is
somehow some of the solutions can only
really make science if they operate at
global scale and there's no connection
between the two excellent any other
reflections on that not ever thinking
that you've arrived at the solution and
and continuing like whatever you're
doing and whatever institution you're
trying to change or tear down or
whatever your relationship to
institution is like do you have to just
constantly iterate you're thinking about
it
and say how can I do this better and how
do you deal with this this definition of
progress how's that are you that first
let's see me mama four of us forget him
yeah well just enough he's he's saying
that we may be purveying a certain kind
of progress this is what what what are
we doing institutionally which shifts
the the paradigm of that I mean I mean I
I've been working with many institutions
but what I do believe that we can
transform people people make
institutions so the institutions are
made of people so I can't believe we
can't change institutions like that's
from my point of view but we we we can't
change people and broken chains
institutions please hello my name is
Annie and my question is how are you
engaging the media to to be able to
disseminate your information and your
technology and the work that you do to
like a wide audience but not have the
media like warp what you're doing
because I the media has like the power
to either like put your on a pedestal or
just like rip you apart um and I think
it's especially important in this kind
of political climate so just and any
like major strategies you guys have been
doing I think the question is what works
I mean one of the reasons that we're all
here tonight is is really to take this
up to another level in terms of
visibility and understanding I'm hoping
that you'll be tweeting the minute you
get away from the microphone and that
other people will be so there's
something that we can all do to say
let's put folks like this in the
headlines rather than other leaders that
we really have got grown tired of seeing
in the headlines and and this is really
part of it but what are there concrete
things that that is giving you a media
franchise terrible work almost against
what we are saying what we are doing
because media everyday is telling people
to lose hope basically every day the
whole thing if you watch the news so if
you have an idea on how to engage media
of promoting good things in the world I
would love to hear also something that
really bothers me yeah I mean one can do
is that
of globalization of the compression of
time and space but nowadays about a
compression of ideas sites and so it
straight eyes TED talk things like that
I think what we have to do is get better
at compressing our ideas because
otherwise our gonna get a transmission
you can't keep on having you know
general length interactions with the
rest of the world and still hope to get
your message through and so what we have
to trim their eyes how do we compress
our ideas and get it transmitted good we
have one minute to do that ok hello my
name is Allegra and my question is in
the introductions and in your speeches
as well we touched a lot about
cross-disciplinary and cross-cultural
communication in terms of like
developing your projects and I was just
wondering what
how have you ensure that this kind of
communication happened or perhaps what
difficulties did you face in ensuring
that how did you get your message across
across cultures thank you maybe any any
one cultures yeah are you gonna cast
disciplines across sectors across yeah I
think it was my personal my personal
experiences is that there is a global
there is sort of a global impact that is
visible and that that is is the end is
the is the end goal that I think
everybody shares and it's not too much
about the person that is making the
optical gadget the person is doing the
electronics the person that is you know
3d printing it's really about the fact
that ultimately ultimately there is this
shared vision that this will do
something that can change the status quo
in materials and medicine
in global health or whatever and it's a
human connection and so the it's very
unusual you tend to try to to match
light it's people first you tend to
match like-minded people and the
discipline almost becomes second there
because generally when there is that
that sort of flame inside then then then
the communication and pragmatism happen
naturally and we see that this week I
think we have to come to an end
can we just hear the questions the last
two questions because I've you've been
standing in line for 10 minutes waiting
just your question my name's Joseph I
have a question for bright Symons so in
a place like Nigeria if right so I'm a
native of Nigeria so I'm saying if
there's a single-payer system and if you
have the government just handle the
drugs do you think that perhaps that
would eliminate all of the different
avenues in which you know fake drugs can
be put into the market and can we take
this offline that sounds like a good
technical question ok
hi my name is Kareem thank you guys so
much for your talk this is mainly for a
bright and Rebecca but essentially my
question is both of you are pursuing
social ventures and I feel like a lot of
the time when one pursues a social
venture in order to like raise funding
or raise awareness or get people to be
interested in the product that the
venture is trying to solve or the issue
that the venture is trying to solve it
takes there's a certain like one must be
able to convince other people to care
about others as in it's it's very easy
for like people to get caught up in
their own problems like I'm the Columbia
student I've got classes exams I've got
my own issues to attend to people how do
we convince other people to care
essentially is my question sorry is the
movement right what's a social event you
need to build a movement first before
you build a product right
oh I disagree I think it's about
individual stories I think you could I
think that that empowering people to
speak with their own voices about their
own issues is is the way to generate
compassion and empathy and to mobilize
people to care about something okay
different views and that really shows
that we have a perspective raised of
perspectives tonight right keep in mind
that these folks have really been
selected again for more than 200 people
because they have something that they're
able to do which shifts on an
institutional level that changes
relationships and builds ecologies of
connections and that they're constantly
and I noticed this even today they're
working on themselves their own
narratives the way that they're framing
and thinking about their work so there's
a there's a lot of reflective practice
and there's a lot of feedback that
they're willing to take and they're all
good listeners as well as talkers so
thank all of you for joining this
evening and thank
so let me just say that those of you who
want to have further discussion
especially if you're undergraduates and
graduates there are workshops tomorrow
they're filled up but if you really want
to go go to the Committee on global
thought website and we'll try to
accommodate you so thank you all for
coming
conversation continues thank you
[Applause]